This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. Some months ago, I brought seven key insights from the first decade of Hidden Brain to live stage performances in San Francisco and Seattle. The evenings were electric. Electric. We got so much positive feedback from those two sold out shows that we've decided to launch a tour to more than a dozen cities in the coming months. I'll be coming to Portland, Denver, Minneapolis, Chicago, Austin, Dallas, Boston, Toronto, Clearwater, Fort Lauderdale, Phoenix, Baltimore, Washington, D.C., and Los Angeles. Presale tickets are available right now for listeners like you.
The presale only runs five days. To snap up your tickets, please go to hiddenbrain.org. The presale password is BRAIN, all caps. You can also sign up to say hello and get a photo with me. In some places, you can sign up for an intimate chat with me and a handful of other fans. I'd love to see you there. Again, go to hiddenbrain.org slash tour. Okay, on to today's show.
This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Let's just say this out loud. Romantic relationships are hard. Finding the right relationship and then keeping it alive, this requires effort, skill, and luck. In the last few weeks of our Relationships 2.0 series, we've looked at the power of human connection, insights into negotiation, and the role of tiny interactions in our
daily lives. Please check out those episodes if you've missed them. They are filled with valuable insights from some of the world's most distinguished researchers on these topics. Today, in the final chapter of our Relationships 2.0 series, we tackle the big question. Love. We look at a problem that seems to be as old as humankind. How do we keep love alive?
We've all sat in restaurants next to couples who look like they have been together for decades. They don't talk to each other. They don't touch one another. They barely look at each other. Perhaps you wondered, were they always like this? Was there a time they were madly in love? This week on Hidden Brain, surprising insights into the magic ingredients that keep love alive.
When we talk about falling in love, we usually refer to it as a very special and unusual period, one characterized by thrilling feelings of exhilaration and euphoria. It's widely assumed that these intense feelings of passion and romance cannot last forever, that they will eventually give way to the mundane realities of daily life. But does that have to be so? At Stony Brook University, psychologist Arthur Aaron has pondered this question for decades. Arthur Aaron, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you. Art, in 2009, you and your research assistant set out to look for what you might call a unicorn, for a very unusual kind of individual. What kind of people were you looking for and how did you go about finding them? Well, we were looking for people, we were looking for couples that were very intensely
in love. These were people who'd been married on the average for 20 years. And we basically just asked various people we knew that my collaborators knew and my then graduate student, Bianca Acevedo, who's now a professor, she interviewed them just to see that they really meant it. And sure enough, we were able to find, you know, plenty. I'm curious what these couples told you when they came into your lab. Again, these are people who had been together for a long time, sometimes decades. I understand one couple in their 60s
really stood out to you and Bianca. Well, we just basically asked them. They would sit together, and we'd ask them to describe, you know, what's going on in their relationship. You know, these were all people who said they were very intensely in love. And we asked them, what does that mean and how does that work? And Bianca, my favorite story is Bianca told me, one couple said, we always annoy our friends
because we're always all over each other physically. So while they're talking, they're touching each other and doing things like that. So now it's possible that of course that when people say that they are deeply in love and passionately in love, they're just telling you that because they want to make you think that they are in a very happy relationship. So you must have been a little skeptical of what they were saying given that this runs so counter to the stereotype we have about how relationships decline over time. Well, we were.
In fact, that's why we did the study. So we put them in the scanner to look at what their brains look like, you know, what areas become active when they look at pictures of their partner. We've done many earlier studies of people who've just fallen in love, and the key finding was known as the dopamine reward area that would pick up when they look at a picture of their partner versus a, you partner versus a neutral friend. And we found that these people showed the same thing. They showed that activation of the dopamine reward area.
So if I'm visualizing this correctly, you're putting people in a brain scanner and you're showing them pictures of either their beloved or somebody who is just a neutral person or an acquaintance. Well, it's an acquaintance that is of the same gender as their partner, as attractive as their partner. We test for all of that, and they look at the two pictures. I mean, they alternate the two, and we're looking at what goes on in their brain when they're looking at that one.
This is exactly what we did in the initial study of people who had just fallen in love. We find that strong dopamine reward area. One other thing that we didn't find in the long term, we find an indication of anxiety, tension. You know, if you've just fallen in love with someone, you're likely to worry, are they going to leave me? Are some going to happen to them? Whereas if you've been with someone for 20 years, you don't worry about that as much.
So when you scan the brains of people who'd been together for a long time but who reported that they were very intensely in love, besides experiencing this dopamine surge when they saw their partners, you also indicate that they also seem to be a little bit more contented compared to people who had just fallen in love a short time ago. Well, there's another area of the brain that has been found mostly in animals where they've got, you know, a lifelong bond, attachment bond, and we saw that also in the long-term couples. I mean, it's kind of natural if you've been together a while and you and you things are going
well to have that kind of common security. I'm struck that these couples went against the stereotype that we have that passionate love fades over time. You know the honeymoon period is followed by a decline in romantic intensity. Talk about that stereotype art, how widespread it is that we believe that relationships start out very intensely and then they decline over time. Well, overall, there's lots of research showing that relationships tend to decline over time. You know, after 10 years, half of them, at least in the U.S., are divorced or close to half.
You know, and overall, not for everybody, but they tend to decline. And so that seems to be what we think is the standard. So you ran a survey and found that, in fact, these couples are not necessarily unicorns. They might not be a majority of the people who are in relationships, but there is a sizable number of them, right? Yeah. When we did a U.S. nationally representative survey, we found that of people married 10 years or longer, 40% claimed to be very intensely in love. Now that means only 20% of those that got married that are still together, but still that's more than we expected.
When you shared these findings with others, you found that some significant number of people might feel threatened by the findings or even resistant to the idea that couples could be very happy over a long period of time. Talk about this finding and why that might be the case, Art. Well, there is findings, not from my lab, but from others, showing that one of the ways couples often feel good about themselves is by comparing to other couples. You know, you leave a party and say,
oh, those people always argue, you know, we don't do that as much. But so it's kind of hard to then be told that, no, some people have really passionate relationships. If you don't, as most people don't, it could be a little annoying. On the other hand, it's a reminder that maybe you could do something. We shouldn't just assume that there's nothing we can do. We should look for some way to make it more like that and not just go along with how things are. Many of us assume that long-term relationships necessarily wither over time.
But what if that's not true? And if it's not true, what's the secret of couples whose passion has lasted for decades? When we come back, the science of keeping a long-term relationship vital. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Arthur Aaron is a psychologist at Stony Brook University. He studies how intimate relationships develop over time. Most of us assume that the passion that characterizes a budding relationship
will fade with time. That's just the way it is. But Art has found it doesn't have to be that way. In a series of studies, he's found many couples who report being passionately in love, even after being together for decades. Once Art had this epiphany, he set out to explain it. Art, one clue to the puzzle came from a study you'd conducted in Vancouver very early in your career. It became an iconic study in the field of psychology and was widely known as the bridge
study. Can you describe the setup for me? Yeah. What we did is we went to a part of Vancouver that has a very large bridge way over a river that wobbles. And so when you walk over it, it's a little scary. You could easily fall off. And so we had an attractive woman, young woman standing on the bridge, and when men of appropriate age by himself would walk across, she would stop and say, could I ask you a few questions? I'm a researcher. And she asked some questions and showed him a little thing
where he would write, make a little picture of something. And we said, thank you very much. And if you want to know more about it, you can phone me. And she'd give him the phone number. We also had her stop an equal number of men on a very safe nearby bridge. Okay, so in one case, she's basically stopping men on this shaky bridge that is scary, and she's asking them these questions. And in the other condition, she's standing on a very stable bridge and asking another group of men the very same questions.
So what happens? What we found is that on the shaky bridge, the things, the pictures they wrote or the comments they made were much more, had much more romantic and sexual content, and they were much more likely to phone her. So that was the finding. And we've done follow-up studies too. And the logic is that if you're shaken up and you're not entirely sure of why, and you meet someone who's attractive,
you're likely to think, oh, that's why I'm feeling this. And it turns out that in some other studies done later, it's been replicated many times in various ways, And it turns out that in some other studies done later, it's been replicated many times in various ways, they found that if you're sort of worked up and you meet someone who's unattractive, you're likely to feel strongly disgusted. In other words, you retake the arousal you've gotten, you reinterpret it.
You know, I'm wondering whether this might explain some of the enduring popularity of horror movies where young couples might go and sit in a movie theater and watch something really scary. Yeah. You have to be a little careful. I can tell you a little story. I, some years after we did this study, I ran into a student who attended one of my classes and he said, oh Dr. Aaron, I ran into a student who attended one of my classes, and he said, oh, Dr. Aaron, I just wanted to tell you what happened recently.
I was in India, and I met at this hotel this attractive young woman, and I thought, oh, I know his research. So I said, let's take a bicycle taxi and go out to lunch. Well, those are sort of scary and the heavy traffic. So they took the bicycle taxi and go out to lunch. Well, those are sort of scary in the heavy traffic. So they took the bicycle taxi, they arrived at the place they're going to have lunch, and they got off and she said, oh, that taxi driver is so attractive. So the research experiment worked, but you have to be careful how it's designed, I suppose.
Yes, right. So of course, when couples meet and fall in love for the first time, they experience a lot of what happens on a shaky bridge. You feel unsure, you're uncertain, maybe even a little afraid, you feel jitters and butterflies in your stomach. What you found in the BRID study is that you can almost reverse engineer the process. If you give people the jitters and they're around someone who could potentially be a romantic partner, they're more likely to see the other person as a romantic partner. Yeah, I mean it's only one of the
causes of falling in love. I mean, there's other circumstances that can strongly create it, and we've done research on that. I'm reminded of this story that the psychologist Lisa Feldman Barrett once told me. She's at Northeastern University, and she told me that many years ago when she was in graduate school, there was someone who wanted to go out on a date with her, and she wasn't very interested, and she finally agreed to go out and have coffee with this guy and then she's sitting across from him and suddenly her face is feeling flushed and she's feeling like you know a rush of temperature in her forehead and she's like oh my god maybe I actually was
attracted to this guy and I shouldn't have you know dismissed him out of the hand you know maybe I should you know pursue this and at the end of the date he says can we go out for dinner next and she says yeah let's let's do it and she comes home. And then six seconds later, she has to throw up because she's coming down with the flu. And what she was experiencing was the early symptoms of flu and not sort of romantic attraction.
But it's the same idea, isn't it? Which is that we have these signals that come to us in our minds. And in some ways, our brains have to interpret what the signal is about. And they have to draw a conclusion. This signal is about my feelings for this other person. Right.
Well, that's certainly what happens in a new relationship. But in an ongoing relationship, when you do it together, it's not so much that it's about my feelings about them, it's what we are. The shaky Brit study and Lisa Feldman Barrett's story of the confusing date both point to the same underlying insight. We are often not very good at identifying the source of our feelings. Young men on the shaky bridge experienced jitters because the bridge was unstable. When they happened to meet a young woman, the men confused their jitters
about the bridge as romantic attraction for the woman. More of them followed up and gave the young woman a call. As Art began studying couples in long-term relationships, he had an insight. As couples fall into routines, getting kids ready for school in the mornings, dinner at the kitchen table in the evenings, social activities on the weekends with the same set of friends and neighbours, these activities start to become familiar. Over time, even if these activities are pleasant, they become predictable. Then they can become boring. If people on a shaky bridge confuse their jitters for romantic attraction, what happens if you're in a long-term relationship with someone
and constantly find yourself around the same person when you're feeling bored? I think boredom has a big effect. If everything is going fine, fine, you know, we'll just stay together and enjoy raising our children or enjoy having our house together or, you know, supporting each other. But we've shown that over time
if you're bored, you're less likely to, you know, to feel love or feel even closeness, as much closeness to your partner. Talk about the work that you have done on a longitudinal basis where you interviewed couples over a period of time and asked them about their levels
of boredom and then evaluated how satisfied they were with their relationships down the road. Well, they weren't interviewed in person. They did a questionnaire early on and where they answered a bunch of different questions, three or four of which had to do with boredom. And then we gave them a questionnaire, I don't know, five years later, eight years later or something that focused on closeness using our standard measure of closeness.
And those who had been more bored eight years earlier were likely to now to have less satisfaction. So talk about why this might be the case, Art. I mean, when most people think about the factors that can undermine relationships, they don't think about boredom as being a prime culprit. They might think about infidelity or abusive behavior, but just the ordinary mundane factor of boredom plays a bigger role than many people consider?
Well, I think, especially in our culture and in most modern cultures, you hope for more in a relationship. So if you're feeling bored, you're not getting everything you'd like from it. Hmm. So as you've thought about these ideas for many years, you've developed a more sophisticated theory
about what might be going on here. You say that people have a fundamental desire to expand the self, and that this often occurs through relationships. What do you mean by this art? Well, we've shown that there's a whole bunch of evolutionary work, is that one main evolutionary thing is survival. Well, we've shown that there's a whole bunch of evolutionary work.
One main evolutionary thing is survival. The other is growth, change, expansion, what we call expansion. You want to increase who you are, to increase your resources, increase your knowledge. The other thing we've shown in our research is that when you form a relationship, the other becomes part of who you are. Relationships are a major way that you can expand rapidly. So when you get close to someone, you include them in the self. And that means that you grow because you've included their resources, their knowledge,
their experiences. So you grow. And when that happens at the beginning it's a rapid expansion of the self and it's very rewarding. Over time it's not that exciting anymore because it's not new expansion. And when you say that our partners help to expand us is it just because they bring new interests, new passions, new avocations of their own into our lives? Well, yes, but they also become part of us.
So their abilities and their resources, we actually mix up with our own, you know, we've done a lot of research showing that we mix up memories, we mix up, you know, who has what qualities, all sorts of stuff. I sometimes think I know things my partner knows that I don't or that, you know, that sort of thing. So you feel you know more than you did. You feel you have more resources than you did, you know, all sorts of things. And can you speak a moment about what that drive is about, the drive of basically growth and expansion, you sort of describe it as a fundamental drive.
Talk a little bit more about that. Where does that come from and how does that manifest in our lives? Well, I think you want to be able to do more, to get more, to acquire more. It's just normal and natural and to explore and find new things that make life better. And so we're wired to have that. This idea of growth and wanting to know more, explore all of that seeking growth and expansion and creativity. All of that is a long-term understanding and evolutionary
psyche and it's well documented. Hmm. I'm wondering whether this means that we are drawn to potential partners who promise us the possibility of expanding ourselves? Yes. If we have a partner who's got resources that's kind of a plus. A partner who is socially valuable is a kind of a plus. A partner who knows a bunch of things is a kind of a plus. It's making us more than we were before. It's giving us more opportunities to do things we couldn't do before. It's not just money and resources. It's creativity, it's opportunities to be able to do things, to feel things more broadly. All of those things we desire as individuals, we can get through a partner in some ways
much more easily. I'm wondering whether there is any truth to the idea then that opposites might attract because of course if you are drawn to somebody who's very different from you, potentially your ability to expand yourself must be greater. Mostly people think that similarity matters hugely. It doesn't matter that much. And in fact, overall, we do like to have differences, and we've shown that in a study,
that if you think the other person has different interests than you do, and they're not competing with you, that's a plus. So if you're interested in the arts and they're interested in science, you're gonna each gain from each other. I'm wondering if one of the implications of this model
is that when we first fall in love, the sense of self-expansion is an overdrive. And is it possible that some of the euphoria we feel when we fall in love is not just because we are drawn to this other person But in some ways we are drawn to the kind of person that we are growing into that in some ways It's we are drawn to our own self expansion and that's part of the euphoria of falling in love Yes, we want to feel we like to feel that sense of I'm gonna be more now being with them I'm gonna have a fuller life. I'm going to have more opportunities,
more knowledge, more interests, more ways to make life enjoyable and interesting. All of that stuff. So from that perspective, I'm wondering what this research has to say about the effects of long-term relationships. In other words, when we are in long-term relationships, there's obviously a certain amount of familiarity that creeps in because of course, you know this other person. You've been with this other person for five years, ten years, fifteen years, twenty years. Is it possible that this other person just naturally then stops helping you expand? Because in some ways, you know that person very well, and they know you very well, and this might be a source of boredom? Well, yes. I mean, the the other person you've already expanded by
including them. I mean if you were to break up with them you would lose that. We've shown it's hard to break up a relationship if you have a lot of a sense of expansion including them in the self. So no, the process of getting there is exciting but once you're there you get used to it. You wouldn't want to lose it, but you get used to it. Now, if you or your partner, if you do something exciting together, you associate that with the partner. If you have some expansion together, or if your partner has an expansion that you can feel connected to, even as an individual, that can be expanding to the self.
Art's research on the effects of novelty and challenge and on the process of self-expansion suggests a tantalizing possibility. Is the key to keeping long-term relationships romantic and passionate in our own hands. When we come back, practical ways to keep boredom at bay and make a relationship continue to feel exciting and alive. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
Arthur Aaron is a psychologist at Stony Brook University. He studies how to keep love alive. Art, in the late 1960s, you were enrolled in a doctoral program at the University of California Berkeley. You were a teaching assistant and helping to instruct a class. Something important in your life happened at the end of that class. Can you paint a picture of what happened for me? There was a student in the class who I had a lot of sort of conflict with.
The last day of class, we walked out. We looked at each other. I can still remember this so vividly. We looked at each other a minute and we kissed. And from that moment on, we'd been living together. We just celebrated our 50th anniversary. It was so intense and in fact it's really what prompted my studying love. I was a graduate student in social psychology and the idea then was to look for a topic that people think can't be studied scientifically and
do it. And there was very little research on love at that time. So that became, you know, what I decided to study. But no, I fell intensely in love with this woman. So what was it like in the early days of the relationship, Art, when you and the student, whose name was Elaine, got together? What was it like in those first few days and months? It was wonderful. About two months later, we started living together.
It was very intense and wonderful. We made a big decision a couple years later to have a baby. We didn't want to get married because, you know, coming from Berkeley in those years, we didn't want to get married because, you know, coming from Berkeley in those years, we didn't like the idea. But when our son was four years old, he came home and said, Mommy, what's a bastard? And we thought we'd better get married. So we've been living together actually 57 years, but we've been married for 50. Given that Art is a psychologist, it's perhaps not surprising that he examined the moment
he and Elaine fell in love and asked himself what happened between them psychologically. In time, he and his colleagues explored whether love could be engineered between two strangers. They came up with a list of questions that people could ask one another that would get them to open up, to share, to make themselves vulnerable. Years later, this research went viral in a New York Times article titled, The 36 Questions That Lead to Love. Art said that in this research, they paired up strangers
and had them sit across from one another. The questions were divided into three sections. Over a 45-minute encounter, the couple would pose questions from each section to each other. The researchers gave volunteers specific instructions. One is that each would answer the question, and then the other would answer, and they on so they could hear each other and have a chance to be responsive.
Another element was the questions were designed so that they moved from not being very intimate or close to being more and more intimate stuff. You know, if you get on a plane and you talk about, you sit down with someone, you start talking about the most intense things in your life, you can put them off. So if you start with, you know, smaller things and then gradually move to bigger, and you go both ways. So it's just, so the first set is fairly mundane, you know, if you go out to dinner with anyone in the world throughout history, who would you go out to dinner, you know, and then they get more and more personal. The researchers encouraged volunteers to identify things they had in common. Of course, people do this in real life all the time. We like others who share our passions for music or sports. What the researchers were doing was to force the volunteers to identify such commonalities.
One of the things that makes people want to get close is to feel they have things in common. Actually having them isn't as important as feeling they do. In the second set, I think we have an item that say, name some things you've noticed you have in common. We never say name some things you don't have in common. So in set one, I'm looking at the list of questions right now.
You know, you have questions like, what would constitute a perfect day for you, or when did you last sing to yourself, or if you were able to live to the age of 90 and retain either the mind or the body of a 30-year-old for the last 60 years of your life, which would you want? And these are, I guess these are interesting questions, these are the kind of questions you might ask a stranger at a bar, but they're not particularly intimate or deep. Yeah. And even those get a little stronger as you move ahead, but yes, within the first twelve. And so the next twelve starts to ask even deeper questions. What is your most treasured
memory? What is your most terrible memory? What roles do love and affection play in your life? How do you feel about your relationship with your mother? And these are the questions that you could imagine asking someone once you've gotten to know them. Now typically I think most people in real life might get to asking those questions after getting to know someone for a few weeks or a few months. You're sort of accelerating the process in some ways by having them ask these questions in the second 15-minute bout. Yeah that's right. That's the idea. We want to create closeness in 45 minutes. And I'm wondering what happens as you do this. The last set of questions in some ways get to very intense questions.
记忆？你最可怕的记忆是什么？爱和温情在你的生活中扮演什么角色？你如何看待你与母亲的关系？这些都是你可以想象在了解某人之后问他们的问题。通常我认为现实生活中的大多数人在了解一个人几周或几个月后才会问这些问题。在某种程度上，你通过让他们在第二个15分钟的环节中问这些问题，加速了这个过程。是的，没错。这就是主意。我们希望在45分钟内建立亲密感。我想知道当你这样做时会发生什么。在某种程度上，最后一组问题触及了非常激烈的问题。
You know, when did you last cry in front of another person? If you were to die this evening with no opportunity to communicate with anyone, what would you most regret not having told someone? I mean, very, very intense and personal questions. What happens when you put volunteers through these sets of questions, Art? Well, they get closer. This closest procedure in 45 minutes really works. It doesn't necessarily keep them close in the long term, but certainly right afterwards
你知道，你上次在另一个人面前哭是什么时候？如果你今晚就要死去，没有机会与任何人交流，你最后悔没有告诉别人的是什么？我的意思是，非常、非常激烈和私人的问题。当你让志愿者经历这些问题时会发生什么，阿特？嗯，他们变得更亲密了。这套在45分钟内建立亲密感的程序真的很管用。它不一定会让他们长期保持亲密关系，但绝对在事后
they often report feeling as close to the person they were doing the activity with as to the closest person in their life. It really creates a sense of intense closeness. Art says the experimental intervention underscored a number of important points. First, self-disclosure, revealing things about yourself to someone else, is key to deepening relationships. But it's not just because people feel closer to those to whom they reveal secrets. It's because when we share things that reveal who we really are, it allows other people to respond with compassion and understanding.
他们经常报告说，他们对一起做这项活动的人感到的亲密程度，就像对他们生活中最亲密的人一样。它确实创造了一种强烈的亲密感。阿特说，这项实验性干预凸显了几个重要观点。首先，自我披露，即向别人透露关于你自己的事情，是加深关系的关键。但这不仅仅是因为人们对向其吐露秘密的人感觉更亲密。这是因为当我们分享揭示我们真实身份的事情时，它允许其他人以同情和理解做出回应。
Self-disclosure is a trigger for other people's responsiveness. Art and researchers like former Hidden Brain guest Harry Reese feel that it's responsiveness that is the glue for relationships. Self-disclosure provides an opportunity for deep responsiveness. You know, when you interact with someone and you know, you say something and you feel they've heard you, they understand you, they care about you, that matters a lot. It might seem obvious, but another powerful idea embedded in the questions
自我披露是引发他人回应的触发器。阿特和像前“隐藏的大脑”嘉宾哈里·里斯这样的研究人员认为，正是回应性构成了关系的黏合剂。自我披露为深度的回应提供了机会。你知道，当你与某人互动时，你知道，你说了一些话，你觉得他们听到了你，他们理解你，他们在乎你，这非常重要。这似乎显而易见，但这些问题中蕴含的另一个强有力的观点是
is they ask people to share what they like about each other. Very often, as we go through life, we notice things about other people that we like or admire. Few of us take the time to actually voice these thoughts aloud. How much of a difference does that make? That's a huge effect. Feeling someone likes you, it really matters for getting close to them. In fact, it's a major factor that we found
它们要求人们分享他们彼此喜欢的地方。很多时候，在我们度过人生的过程中，我们会注意到其他人身上我们喜欢或钦佩的地方。我们很少有人花时间真正把这些想法大声说出来。这会带来多大的差异？这是一个巨大的影响。觉得有人喜欢你，这对拉近与他们的距离真的很重要。事实上，这是我们发现的一个主要因素
in falling in love. You know, we've done a lot of surveys where we ask people who've recently fallen in love, what happened? And a major thing is I discovered the other person liked me. So for example, a person is saying, you know, I've met this woman and, you know, I kind of liked her and I ran into her at a store and she looked at me and she
在坠入爱河的过程中。你知道，我们做过很多调查，我们问那些最近坠入爱河的人，发生了什么？一个主要的因素是，我发现对方喜欢我。例如，一个人说，你知道，我遇到了这个女人，你知道，我有点喜欢她，我在一家商店里遇到了她，她看着我，她
smiled at me. And at that moment I fell in love. I've heard so many stories like that. At that moment where I discovered, my friend said, oh, you know this person likes you, don't you? Those sorts of things. They really can matter a lot, you know. Oh I ran into this person again and he sat down next to me, you know. You know, those kinds of things really matter. In a longer intervention Art and his colleagues went even further to engineer a feeling of closeness between two people. The longer one is an hour and a half and it has a lot of questions towards the end that, you know, imagine you fall in love with this person, tell them what you feel.
对我笑了笑。那一刻我坠入了爱河。我听过太多这样的故事了。在那一刻，我发现，我的朋友说，哦，你知道这个人喜欢你，对吧？诸如此类的事情。它们确实非常重要，你知道的。哦，我又遇到了这个人，他在我旁边坐下了，你知道的。你知道，诸如此类的事情真的很重要。在一次更长时间的干预中，阿特和他的同事们走得更远，旨在人为制造两个人之间的亲密感。较长的那一次是一个半小时，快结束时有很多问题，你知道的，想象你爱上了这个人，告诉他们你的感受。
You know, things like that. It also has the item people talk about a lot that are not in the 36 questions, but look in their eyes for three minutes in each other's eyes. Things like that towards the end that really are aimed at creating romantic feelings. We tried to be very careful doing that study
你知道，诸如此类的事情。它还包含人们经常谈论但不在36个问题中的项目，即互相注视三分钟，注视对方的眼睛。快结束时诸如此类真正旨在创造浪漫感觉的事情。我们在做那项研究时尽量非常小心
not to include people who are already in relationships. Two of the students in my lab tried this out, you know, to experiment, and they literally fell in love, and they got married. Wow. Wow. So, we've discussed how the 36 questions were intended to create a sense of closeness between strangers. They were not intended necessarily to improve or deepen an already existing relationship between people who had been together for 10 years or 20 years. But you found that there's a way to make the questions useful for couples who've been together for a long time, and this insight involves other couples. Walk me through this idea, Art.
不把已经处于恋爱关系中的人包含在内。我实验室里的两个学生尝试了这个，你知道，作为实验，他们真的坠入爱河了，然后他们结婚了。哇。哇。所以，我们讨论了这36个问题是如何旨在陌生人之间创造亲密感的。它们不一定旨在改善或加深已经在一起10年或20年的两个人之间现有的关系。但你发现有一种方法可以使这些问题对长期在一起的伴侣有用，而这个见解涉及其他伴侣。阿特，请带我了解这个想法。
Well, there'd been, been again a lot of survey research showing that when you have close friends the relationships are better. So we were able to randomly assign couples to do this as a couple with another so they answer all the four of them answered each question and we found that after doing this as a foursome it much increased their passionate love for each other. It doesn't make you love the other people. It makes you like them better, feel more close to them.
嗯，之前有很多调查研究表明，当你拥有亲密的朋友时，关系会更好。所以我们能够随机分配伴侣，让他们作为一对伴侣与另一对伴侣一起做这件事——他们回答所有问题，四个人都回答了每个问题——我们发现作为四人组做完这件事后，大大增加了他们彼此之间炽热的爱情。它不会让你爱上其他人。它会让你更喜欢他们，对他们感觉更亲密。
It increases your passionate love for your partner. And why do you think that's happening? Well, we did some tests of why, and the main reason seems to be responsiveness. When you're with another couple and you're talking about deep things, you tend to be more responsive to your own partner. All four of you answer each question, you know, and it's that greater sense of responsiveness that you experience that really makes a difference.
它会增加你对伴侣炽热的爱。你认为这是为什么呢？嗯，我们对原因做了一些测试，主要原因似乎是回应性。当你和另一对伴侣在一起并谈论深刻的事情时，你往往会对自己的伴侣更有回应。你们四个人都回答每个问题，你知道，正是你所经历的这种更强的回应感，才真正带来了改变。
In recent years, Art and his colleagues have started to look for other ways to help couples in long-term relationships keep love alive. Many of them go back to that insight from the BRID study. When people experience an emotion when they are in the company of another person, they tend to associate that person with the emotion they are feeling. If you spend a lot of time around someone and feel bored, you'll come to think of that person as boring. But if you can spend a lot of time around the person doing interesting and novel things,
近年来，阿特和他的同事们开始寻找其他方法，来帮助长期关系的伴侣保持爱火不熄。其中许多方法可以追溯到“BRID”研究中的那个见解。当人们在另一个人的陪伴下体验某种情绪时，他们往往会把那个人与他们正在体验的情绪联系起来。如果你花很多时间和一个让你觉得无聊的人在一起，你就会认为那个人很无聊。但如果你能花很多时间陪伴这个人，做有趣和新奇的事情，
you'll come to associate that person with surprise and growth. Art says he and Elaine try to put this idea into practice. You know, we try every week at least to do something new and different and we do some big adventures. You know, usually every summer we take a trip to Europe and go to some place we've never been before and hike from village to village. One summer we did something really exciting.
你就会把这个人与惊喜和成长联系起来。阿特说，他和伊莱恩试图将这个想法付诸实践。你知道，我们每周至少尝试做一些新颖和不同的事情，我们会进行一些大的冒险。你知道，通常每年夏天我们都会去欧洲旅行，去一些我们从未去过的地方，从一个村庄徒步到另一个村庄。有一个夏天，我们做了一件非常激动人心的事情。
We went down the Colorado River in the Grand Canyon went down the Colorado River in the Grand Canyon on a floating boat with about seven or eight other people and with a friend of ours. And it was intense, but it was really wonderful. I mean, in general, the more exciting and interesting the things you do with your partner, you then associate with your partner. And when it's difficult and you overcome the difficulties, that's a big plus too.
我们乘坐漂流船和大约七八个人以及我们的一个朋友一起顺着科罗拉多河进入了大峡谷，顺着科罗拉多河进入了大峡谷。那很刺激，但也真的很棒。我的意思是，总的来说，你和伴侣一起做的越是刺激和有趣的事情，你随后就会将这些事情与你的伴侣联系起来。当事情变得艰难而你们克服了困难时，这也是一个巨大的加分项。
That's expanding. Art told me that you don't need to go on expensive vacations in order to find novelty. He says daily activities, where you go for a walk or what you eat for dinner, can also provide such novelty. Yes, we make a point of doing something new and interesting every week at least. We go to concerts and ballets but we never go to the same ones, you know, and we really enjoy the do-ness, the change. I understand that one time you were coming back from a play and you walked by a bar and you noticed that you hadn't hung out in a bar for a long time. Tell me the story of what happened that night.
那是拓展。阿特告诉我，你不需要为了寻找新鲜感而去昂贵的度假。他说日常活动，比如去散步或晚饭吃什么，也能提供这种新鲜感。是的，我们特别坚持每周至少做一些新颖有趣的事情。我们去听音乐会和看芭蕾舞，但我们绝不去同一个地方，你知道，我们真的很享受这种行动力、这种改变。我听说有一次你从一场戏剧回来时，路过一家酒吧，你注意到你已经很久没有在酒吧闲逛了。给我讲讲那天晚上发生了什么的故事。
Well, we were in New York at the time and we went to a lot of plays and we were walking back from a play past a bar. And when we go into the bar, we've never done that before. We haven't done that in years and years. We used to when we were younger. So we went in and had a good time. Another time Art and Elaine met up at a bar and pretended to be strangers meeting each other for the first time. We went down to this place and we both sat there. One came in a little before the other. The other sat down near, I don't know who came in first, but the other one came in and sat
嗯，我们当时在纽约，我们看了很多戏剧，我们看完戏步行回来时路过一家酒吧。当我们走进酒吧时，我们以前从未那样做过。我们已经好几年没这么做过了。我们年轻时经常去。所以我们进去了，玩得很开心。还有一次，阿特和伊莱恩在一家酒吧见面，假装是第一次相遇的陌生人。我们去了那个地方，我们俩都坐在那里。一个人比另一个人稍微早一点进来。另一个人坐在附近，我不知道谁先来的，但另一个人进来坐下
near them and you know had some small discussion. Oh hi, how are you? them and, you know, had some small discussion. Oh, hi, how are you? I'm, you know, I don't remember what name I used and talked about what we did and, you know, which was not what we actually do, but it was kind of fun and we pretended like we were just meeting and that was a fun activity. We talked for a while and then basically went home as if it was a hotel and had some fun. Uh-huh. So I think a lot of couples who've been together for a while say, you know, we regularly plan to do activities
在他们附近，你知道，进行了一些简短的交谈。哦，嗨，你好吗？在他们附近，你知道，进行了一些简短的交谈。哦，嗨，你好吗？我，你知道，我不记得我用过什么名字，还谈论了我们做过的事，你知道，这其实不是我们平时做的事，但挺好玩的，我们假装我们刚见面，那是一个有趣的活动。我们聊了一会儿，然后基本上就像去酒店一样回家了，玩得很开心。嗯哼。所以我认为很多在一起一段时间的伴侣会说，你知道，我们经常计划去做一些活动
that we both enjoy. We might go out to a restaurant. We might go and watch a movie. These are pleasant activities. But you're saying pleasant is actually not enough. That's right. I mean, it doesn't hurt. But if you can do more than that, you know, let's go to a restaurant. Let's go to one we've never been to before.
我们俩都喜欢。我们可能会去餐厅。我们可能会去看电影。这些都是令人愉快的活动。但你是说愉快其实还不够。没错。我的意思是，这没有坏处。但如果你能做更多的事情，你知道，我们去一家餐厅吧。我们去一家从未去过的餐厅吧。
You know, let's go to a kind of restaurant we've never been to before. You know, let's do something really different. You know, that's what matters. And you've run experiments along these lines where you actually ask people to do activities that are either pleasant or exciting. So you're actually trying to distinguish between those two things, between the novel and the pleasant.
你知道，我们去一种从未去过的那种餐厅吧。你知道，我们做一些真正不同的事情吧。你知道，这才是最重要的。你曾沿着这些路线进行实验，你实际上要求人们去做那些要么令人愉快要么令人兴奋的活动。所以你实际上是在试图区分这两件事，区分新奇与愉快。
Yeah, well, we've done experiments in the lab, but one of the early things we did is we gave couples a long list of activities, and they had to rate each on a number of things, including how exciting it would be to do this. This is a standard list of activities people do. Then we took a subset of the things that they listed as exciting,
是的，我们在实验室里做过实验，但我们早期做的事情之一是，我们给伴侣们列出了一长串活动，他们必须对每一项活动的许多方面进行评分，包括这样做会有多兴奋。这是一份人们会做的活动的标准清单。然后我们从中抽取了一部分他们列为兴奋的活动，
but not particularly pleasant, not unpleasant, but you know, and randomly assigned half of them to do something from that list and half to do something from the other items. And every week to do, spend a half hour to an hour doing one of these things are a little longer. And we had them do this for 10 weeks. And we found that those who were
但不是特别愉快，也不是不愉快，但你知道的，然后随机分配一半的人做该清单中的活动，另一半人做其他项目中的活动。每周花半小时到一小时做其中一件事，或者稍微久一点。我们让他们这样做了10周。我们发现那些处于
in the exciting activity group showed much bigger increase in the quality of their relationships than the other one. Hmm. So in other words, if I and my partner, for example, don't particularly think of rock climbing or bungee jumping as pleasant, but we would find it very exciting and novel, what you're suggesting is that doing these activities together
兴奋活动组的人，其关系的质量比另一组有了更大的提升。嗯。所以换句话说，如果我和我的伴侣，例如，并不特别认为攀岩或蹦极是令人愉快的，但我们会发现它非常刺激和新奇，你的意思是，一起做这些活动
in some ways can prompt us to feel closer to one another than if we engaged in merely pleasant activities. Yeah well it's nice if the activity is both pleasant and novel but as long as it's again as long as it's not more than you can handle. Yeah in one of your studies Art you had couples engage in an unusual activity where you tied their wrists and ankles together. Now, this can seem a little risque, but I understand this was a family-friendly experiment? Yes.
在某些情况下，会促使我们比仅仅从事令人愉快的活动时感觉彼此更亲密。是的，如果这项活动既愉快又新奇，那是很好的，但只要它再次发生，只要它没有超出你能应付的范围。是的，在你的其中一项研究中，阿特，你让伴侣们从事了一项不寻常的活动，你把他们的手腕和脚踝绑在了一起。现在，这可能看起来有点冒险，但我了解到这是一个适合家庭的实验？是的。
Yeah. They came into the lab and we said, we're going to have you do some things. And in one condition, we tied their wrists and ankles together with Velcro strips and we had them go across, I don't know, it was about 25 feet or something on gym mats and there was a big round rolled thing in the middle. And they had to go back and forth over it. And they had to beat a certain number of minutes to win. And then we had a control condition
是的。他们来到实验室，我们说，我们要让你们做一些事情。在一种情况下，我们用魔术贴带子把他们的手腕和脚踝绑在一起，让他们在体操垫上穿过，我不知道，大约25英尺左右，中间有一个巨大的圆柱形滚动的东西。他们必须来回翻越它。他们必须在一定的时间内获胜。然后我们有一个控制组
where one of them would go back and forth and the other would watch, and they enjoyed that. You know, it was pleasant. But we found that those doing the exciting one together, the more interesting one together, showed a big increase in their feeling of love. Art says, the key is not getting your heart rate up during the activity.
其中一个人来回走动，另一个人看着，他们很享受。你知道，这很愉快。但我们发现那些一起做刺激的事情的人，一起做更有趣的事情的人，他们的爱意感有了很大的提升。阿特说，关键不在于在活动期间让心率加快。
It's about doing something unusual. Just doing something arousing with your partner that's not new and interesting like going to the gym together or something does not increase your love for your partner. Doing something new and interesting that is not necessarily arousing does. Now it doesn't hurt if you have both In a long-term relationship what matters is doing things that are not what interesting with your partner It's not just doing them and having your partner nearby. It's doing them Together so you feel yes, I'm having this feeling but I'm sharing it with my partner
重点在于做一些不寻常的事。和你的伴侣一起做一些让人兴奋但并不新颖有趣的事情，比如一起去健身房之类的，并不能增加你对伴侣的爱。做一些不一定令人兴奋但新颖有趣的事情则可以。当然，如果两者兼具就更好了。在长期的关系中，重要的是和你的伴侣做那些绝非无趣的事情。不仅仅是做这些事而你的伴侣就在附近。而是你们一起做
So this is part of who we are as a couple. Some of your research points toward the importance of engaging in activities with your partner that involve humor. Why would this be important art? Well, it's because it's sort of expanding again to feel humor with your partner. You go to a comedy show or something like that. It riles you up in a good way. It feels new and interesting, and you're sharing it. It makes you feel connected with him.
所以这构成了我们作为伴侣的一部分。你的一些研究指出了与伴侣从事涉及幽默的活动的重要性。阿特，为什么这很重要？嗯，这是因为它再次起到了拓展作用，与你的伴侣一起体验幽默。你去喜剧表演或类似的地方。它以一种好的方式让你情绪高涨。它感觉新奇有趣，而且你们在分享。这让你觉得与他有联系。
It makes you feel you're one. We've done a lot of research on that, showing how you become one with the other. Not quite fully one, but close to one. You also found that one way to create a certain amount of unpredictability in relationships is to engage in activities with your partner that involve friendships with other couples.
它让你觉得你们合二为一。我们对此做了很多研究，展示了你如何与另一个人合二为一。虽不完全是一体，但接近一体。你还发现，在关系中产生一定程度不可预测性的方法之一，是与伴侣一起从事涉及与其他伴侣建立友谊的活动。
Why does this matter? Oh, close friendships with other couples really matters a lot. There's a lot of correlational research, a lot of survey research showing this. And we did some experiments using our 36 questions where we had both couples do this together. And we showed that one of the causalities is, you know, if you're close to another couple, you spend time with them and you talk about deep things, you feel deeply connected, that creates a sense of you appreciate your partner's
为什么这很重要？哦，与其他伴侣建立亲密友谊非常重要。有很多相关研究，很多调查研究都表明了这一点。我们利用我们的36个问题做了一些实验，让两对伴侣一起做这件事。我们表明，其中的因果关系之一是，你知道，如果你和另一对伴侣很亲密，你花时间与他们相处并谈论深刻的事情，你就会感到深深的连接，这会产生一种让你欣赏伴侣的感觉——
responsiveness to you even. In that context your partner tends to be more responsive, which is a really important element in relationships. Feeling your partner is responsive. Being responsive to your partner is good, but feeling your partner is responsive. Being responsive to your partner is good, but feeling your partner is responsive to you. They hear you, they understand you, they care about you. Those are crucial. Last summer we went on a bar strip with one of our closest couple friends. So we had both an exciting activity and a novel, challenging activity. Never been on a bar strip down a river in Scotland, you know. And we also had it with a close friend, so it had a double effect.
甚至是你伴侣对你的回应。在这种情况下，你的伴侣往往更有回应性，这在亲密关系中是一个非常重要的元素。觉得你的伴侣是有回应的。对你的伴侣有回应是好的，但觉得你的伴侣对你是有回应的。他们倾听你，他们理解你，他们在乎你。这些都至关重要。去年夏天，我们和我们最亲密的伴侣朋友之一去了一次酒吧巡游。所以我们既有刺激的活动，又有新颖、具挑战性的活动。从来没有在苏格兰的一条河流顺流而下进行过酒吧巡游，你知道的。而且我们也是和一个好朋友一起去的，所以它有双重效果。
Art says he decided to follow his research findings and not his gut when Elaine asked to go on a whale watching trip. Art gets seasick, but he recognized that the trip was important to his wife and would be a novel activity. Well, to prepare for the trip, I got some pills that are supposed to help you. I got a patch I could put on.
阿特说，当伊莱恩要求去参加一次观鲸之旅时，他决定遵循他的研究结果，而不是他的直觉。阿特晕船，但他意识到这次旅行对他的妻子很重要，也将是一项新颖的活动。好吧，为了准备这次旅行，我买了一些据说有用的药。我买了一个可以贴上的贴片。
I got a thing I put on my wrist. I did all these things that people talk about help you deal with, because I knew I get seasick easily. And of course, we've since then done a little whale watching on a very large flat boat not not in a Difficult ocean it went okay, but this time We were going out into the San Francisco not the bay beyond the bay and it's very rough water And it was just too much. I fed the whales the whole time
我买了一个戴在手腕上的东西。我做了所有那些人们说能帮你应对的事情，因为我知道我很容易晕船。当然，从那以后，我们在一个非常大的平底船上做过一点观鲸，不是在困难的海洋里，情况还算过得去，但这次我们要去旧金山湾以外的地方，那里的水非常波涛汹涌。实在太厉害了。我一直在鲸鱼面前吐
leaning over the edge. So another way to introduce freshness in a relationship is to find ways to celebrate a partner's successes. Many of us think that relationships are about supporting a partner in bad times. You say it might be even more important to focus on good times? Yeah, there's research showing that celebrating your partner's successes matters even more than supporting when things go badly, although that also matters. My wife studies something called
靠在边缘。所以在关系中引入新鲜感的另一种方法是寻找庆祝伴侣成功的方法。我们许多人认为，关系就是要在糟糕的时期支持伴侣。你说专注于美好的时光可能更重要？是的，有研究表明，庆祝伴侣的成功比在事情进展不顺时给予支持更重要，尽管支持也很重要。我的妻子研究一种叫做
the highly sensitive person, and I collaborate with her on that, just like she collaborates with me on our relationship research. Well, the very first time I read the paper talking about the role of it being important to celebrate your partner's successes, she had recently submitted a paper to a very top scientific journal. I was a co-author, but it was basically her paper. And we thought it had a poor chance of getting accepted, but we gave it a chance.
高度敏感的人，我和她在这方面合作，就像她和我合作研究我们的关系一样。好吧，当我第一次读到那篇讨论庆祝伴侣成功的重要性的作用的论文时，她最近刚刚向一家顶级科学杂志提交了一篇论文。我是合著者，但基本上是她的论文。我们以为它被接受的可能性很小，但我们还是试了一下。
Before she came home, I got an email from the editor saying the reviewers loved it, I loved it, this is a great paper, we're gonna publish it, and so I made a poster of that and put it on the front door for when she came home. And so the first thing she saw when she came home was this big poster saying that her paper had been accepted in the journal? Yes. And I think even beyond the fact that she must have been very happy about the paper being accepted, what she's also hearing in that moment is that you are so happy for her that you've gone to some lengths to celebrate it. Yes, yeah, that's true. We had a
在她回家之前，我收到了编辑的一封邮件，说审稿人们很喜欢它，我也很喜欢，这是一篇很棒的论文，我们要发表它，所以我做了一张海报把它贴在前门上，等她回家时看。所以她回家时看到的第一件事就是这张大海报，上面写着她的论文被那家杂志接受了？是的。我想除了她一定对论文被接受感到非常高兴之外，她在那个时刻听到的也是你为她感到如此高兴，以至于你不遗余力地去庆祝它。是的，嗯，那是真的。我们度过了一个
great night, as you can imagine. Arthur Aaron is a psychologist at Stony Brook University. Art, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. My pleasure. Thank you so much, Shankar. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Today's conversation was the final episode in our Relationships 2.0 series.
正如你能想象的那样，一个美好的夜晚。阿瑟·阿伦是纽约州立大学石溪分校的心理学家。阿特，谢谢你今天来到“隐藏的大脑”。不客气。非常感谢你，尚卡尔。“隐藏的大脑”由“隐藏的大脑”传媒制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲·帕尔、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·夸雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥秋恩·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制作人。我是“隐藏的大脑”的执行主编。今天的对话是我们“关系2.0”系列的最后一集。
If you missed any of the other episodes in the series, you can find them on the Hidden Brain podcast or at hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你错过了该系列的任何其他剧集，你可以在“隐藏的大脑”播客或hiddenbrain.org上找到它们。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。回头见。该剧集尚无评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。